joining me now to react host of the
ingram angle which was the number one
show on election night this week laura
ingram good to be with you hey jesse
great to see you so you've seen this
thing in real time tuesday night you
were there watching
what was the significance
to america on tuesday i think when
people elected joe biden there's a there
was a lot going on right there was
obviously covid they thought you know he
was
a kind of a calming influence after
maybe blm and all the tumult that the
whole year of cove had brought us
and
so they thought you know this joe biden
guy and his obviously incredibly close
election all the contested issues
surrounding it but that he was going to
be kind of a calming force remember he
talked about dignity
bringing dignity back to the process
and then you know what people found and
you and i were warning them about this
they found that joe biden was just too
weak
to ever stand up to the far left so the
far left took over the party
and then they went to town and
everything from critical race theory to
tax policy to climate change to cancel
culture and beyond and so this was a
reaction not just to the education issue
but to all of it it's a significant
development the white house knows it
nancy pelosi knows it and that's why you
know they worked fast and furious to try
to rush through everything they could
before the midterms
so some of the media recognized how
stupid wokism is tearing down statues
paying illegal immigrants hundreds of
thousands of dollars and telling your
kid that they're racist they're warning
the democrats hey
you know this is not gonna go well for
you guys but it seems like the rest of
the left doesn't even get it
how do you see that shaking out i think
you're absolutely right they they view
it
as an ideological struggle purely
so if they even lose next year to them
it's worth it yeah if they can get
universal pre-k if they can get
family leave if they can get thousands
and thousands of new climate core
activists hired or higher eight so
losing the house is worth it to them
that's how dedicated they are to
expanding government increasing you our
independence on our dependents excuse me
on government programs the move slowly
but surely towards socialism
it's worth it to them that so they did
the same thing with obamacare they ran
they rammed that through
and then you know in march of of 2010
and then by november 2010 they got wiped
out in the house but they look they
still have obamacare they do it lasted
they do they want to lock in welfare
socialism climate armies i mean these
are hundreds of thousands of paid
bureaucrats that are
beholden to aoc and you're right aoc's
got a safe seat she doesn't care if they
lose the house receives safe
the squad seats are safe they don't care
and you're right they're just going for
broke and they're going to try to do
whatever they can before the time runs
out jesse you know what i thought was
really
interesting
is in in minneapolis obviously that
ballot initiative was soundly defeated
to defund the police reimagine the
police whatever
um so elon omar represents that district
where the third precinct was burned to
the ground on north uh south lake street
represented that district she was the
number one champion of defunding the
police called the police a cancer on
minneapolis
she was rejected by the people of
minneapolis so what i think a lot of
conservatives are saying rightly so
now it's time to go for her seat now
it's time to go into the inner city
where these these congressmen and
congresswomen have been failing the
people
and
we should be going for broke
on every in every state in every
locality and every school board election
it should be a 50-state strategy to take
back america you're not going to do it
if it's about a few percentage points
here or there that's not enough we have
to roll this thing back from from the
west coast to the east coast and you
cannot be afraid and i think you go for
her seat and you go for uh
you know the entire squad try it should
be one big wipeout of the squad next
year have you heard gutfeld's nickname
for ilhan omar
i i have not mentally ill han omar oh
god
i got it but you're right though
no seat is safe that's how you have to
think about it no seat is safe and i
made this analogy the other day it's
like the war in the pacific you go
island by island you go school district
by school districts state by state and
you start at the grassroots you start at
the local school board you go to the
county commissioner and that's how you
take your country back because the most
of the country doesn't buy this crap
they just don't and i think now i think
tuesday's election shows that we're
united behind this garbage yeah and the
great thing is that in in places like
new jersey if republicans maybe had put
a little bit more money in new jersey
and if you know if some of us had paid
more attention to new jersey
uh new jersey probably would have you
know been taken by citarelli he probably
would have won that governorship it was
a hair's breath away from winning uh
but look we had big victories in seattle
uh school board races long island uh and
and the state was the state senate um
chair in new jersey yep most powerful
person in new jersey state politics he
was unseated by you know the truck
driver yeah paid spent 150 bucks on his
campaign i mean
if the democrats answer to this is
okay we want higher energy prices we
want more supply chain problems we want
to you know make life more difficult for
the american people with all these new
edicts and mandates and rules
it's going to be terrible for us for the
next year but it's going to be great for
the conservative movement going forward
because they're just going to get wiped
out i look at it the exact same way they
shouldn't keep going so left but if they
do
i don't have a problem with it yeah keep
it coming all right laura ingram
everybody the number one show on tuesday
night thank you so much thanks jesse
and check out laura's new fox nation
special california on the edge it's out
right now hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else